CBS News has confirmed that lawyers for
former president Trump had a meeting
yesterday at the justice department as
he faces possible charges on multiple
issues being investigated by a special
counsel for insight into this and much
more we're joined by Bill Barr who
served as attorney general in the Trump
Administration since then he has
criticized a former president on a
number of fronts he's also the author of
I love this title one damn thing after
another Memoirs of an attorney general
which is out in paperback today wherever
you like to buy your books we're happy
to say that bill Barr joins us at the
table this morning good to see you good
to see you Bill Barr listen I know from
reading your book you play a mean
bagpipe but I'm understanding you're not
going to be serenading us today not
today yeah our loss but let's talk about
the meeting yesterday that the Trump
attorneys had with this special counsel
what does it say to you what is the
significance because you know how this
game is played you know this record you
know this song what did it say to you
I think I think that meeting was
probably held to complain about some
aspects of the special counsel's work
because generally the special counsel is
generally independent and can make up
their own mind and I think they probably
went to Maine Justice which is where
this meeting was held to complain of the
claim that the special counsel hasn't
been following the rules but does it say
to you that an indictment is near do you
believe that I suspect it's I suspect
it's there I've said for a while that I
think this is the most dangerous legal
risk facing the former president
uh and if I had to bet I would bet that
it's near you believe there is enough
evidence
well they won't indict if there's not
enough evidence but from what I've seen
there's substantial evidence there
and if there is a Federal indictment
Bill do you think that that hurts him
politically you know it seems that
whenever he's indicted or he's
um under scrutiny his numbers go up the
support goes up the donations go up do
you think a Federal indictment will make
a difference and I know it won't for his
core base so in the media future it
might but I think if the based on the
facts as the facts come out I think over
time people will see that this is not a
case of the Department of Justice you
know conducting a Witch Hunt in fact
they approach this very delicately and
with deference to the president and this
would have gone nowhere had the
president just returned the documents
but he jerked them around for a year and
a half and the question is did he
deceive them and if there's evidence of
that I think people will start to see
that this says more about Trump than it
does the Department of Justice and that
is
that he's so egotistical that he has
this penchant for for conducting you
know risky Reckless acts to show that he
can sort of get away with it it's part
of asserting his his his ego and he's
done this repeatedly at the expense of
all the people who depend on him to
conduct The public's business in an
honorable way and you know we saw that
with both impeachments and there's no
excuse for what he did here whether it's
a crime or not remains to be seen do you
think he deceived them you know this man
very well you think I think the
government believes that I didn't ask to
the government I said do you think you
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know the evidence in that kind of detail
but you also said he didn't act in an
honorable way everybody who knows you
says that you are an honorable man they
may disagree with some of the things you
say or some of the things you do but
they say the core Bill bar is he's an
honorable man and I guess I wonder why
you worked with him for so long seeing
the things that you saw up close and
personal why you stayed as long as you
did well I went into the administration
halfway through and I did it at a time
where I felt he was being treated
unfairly on the russiagate thing I
thought that was a you know it turned
out to be I think a big lie and I felt
that he does he was the duly elected
president and he deserved the chance to
conduct his administration and I went in
because I thought I could help stabilize
things and also have the administration
conducted in an appropriate way and uh
as I I felt the idea that the election
was stolen was a big lie and I wasn't
going to play a part in you called him
on that yeah Mr attorney general uh the
former president Trump is still the odds
on leader of the party and the likely
winner of the primary if it were be to
be held today uh in all 50 states but
you don't think he's going to win the
nomination I know you still hold that
view uh who do you like as an
alternative is it Ron DeSantis is it the
governor of Virginia is it uh the
governor of North Dakota if you're a
republican voter right now you've got a
lot of strong choices out there yeah I
like I like most of the people running I
think they're great and what they show
uh and and people who are locked into
Trump have to start focusing on the
facts and the facts are that we have
Republican leaders who can follow
conservative policies uh and expand the
vote and win crushing victories like
DeSantis did like Governor Kemp in
Georgia like Governor Younkin who's very
popular in Virginia following
conservative policies yeah Trump is
almost unique in his inability to
attract voters he repels people other
than his core base and he's got a strong
psychological hold on that core base so
in 2020 uh the the Democrats coalesced
around Joe Biden right there there was a
point in which the other candidates
dropped out and all the energy went to
him could Republicans who don't have
quite the organizational uh set up that
the Democrats have do the same thing
here so that Trump does not become the
winner by default yeah I hope they have
the self-discipline to do it and I
expect that at the beginning of 24 a lot
of the candidates will pull out I think
it's good that they're out there talking
that's a good process but once they it's
clear they don't have a chance they
should pull out but last time you were
here last time you were here though Mr
attorney general you said if Trump is
you called him his ability is a horror
show he would only deliver chaos if
elected again but you told us at that
time if he were the nominee you would
still support him
yeah yeah I mean I I think you still
support him I don't see myself not
supporting the Republican candidate and
that's it even based on the choice
between because because I think look I I
think Biden is just as you know he has a
different set of problems I think
neither of them in my opinion are fit
for the office and the American people
deserve better but if I'm confronted
with that choice I have to go with
policy who's closest to me on policy so
you're going to lean lean Republican
even if there's a better Democratic
candidate he's well I I'm talking about
Biden here I know but will we see a bill
Barr endorses headline this election
cycle endorses who somebody you're going
to endorse at some point if I become
convinced sure all right may I say that
your book Bill Barr one damn thing after
another is available wherever you like
to buy your books we'll be right back
call them Hill endorse